تزال محاور القتال داخل قطاع غزه تشهد
قتالا عنيفا عبد السلام بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي تتمركز في اكثر من نقطه من قطاع غزه
ولكن التركيز بشكل كبير على المنطقه
الشماليه الوسطى والجنوبيه ما عدا رفح انا
نتحدث عن خان يونس محيط دير البلح ومحيط
مدينه غزه والحياء الشماليه والجنوبيه من
مدينه غزه رغم الانسحابات الكثيره لقوات
الاحتلال من عده مناطق من قطاع غزه ابرزها
في المنطقه الشماليه في هذه المنطقه بعد
ان كانت خريطه التوغل تقريبا بهذا الشكل
اصبحت يمكن القول انها اصبحت بهذا الشكل
ونلاحظ الفرق في في التواجد العسكري
الاسرائيلي في المنطقه الشماليه في
المنطقه ايضا الشرقيه في هذه المنطقه
الغربيه عفوا كان هناك انسحابات في
المنطقه الوسطى كان هناك انسحابات وفي
المنطقه الجنوبيه بين دير البلح وخان يونس
كان هناك انسحابات لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انسحابات لافته حيث ان بين دير
البلح و خان يونس انسحبت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى شارع صلاح الدين اذا ما
دخلنا مباشره الى خان يونس نلاحظ عمليات
الانسحاب التي تنفذها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وتحديدا في المنطقه الشماليه
من خانيونس الجنوبيه من دير البلح في هذه
المنطقه في منطقه المطاحن او مفترق او ما
يعرف بمنطقه المطاحن في هذه النقطه ومفترق
ابو هولي في هذه المنطقه هذه الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه انسحبت من هذه
المنطقه وتركت شارع صلاح الدين طبعا شهود
عيان وصحفيين تحركوا اليوم في هذه المنطقه
على شارع صلاح الدين بين دير البلح وخان
يونس هذا هو شارع صلاح الدين ورصدوا كميه
الدمار الكبير الذي تخلفه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في هذه المنطقه بعد انسحابه من
هذه المنطقه اذا عمليات انسحاب لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من الجهه الشماليه
تقريبا لخان يونس ولكن لا يزال الضغط
متواصلا في الجهه الشرقيه والجنوبيه
الشرقيه تحديدا من جهه بني سهيله عبسان
القراره في الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه من
خانيونس المد مدينه والتواجد والتمركز
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في خانيونس في
منطقه البلديه في هذه النقطه تذهب قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تتمركز في منطقه
البلديه تنفذ عمليات هجوم وتتراجع في هذه
المنطقه مع ايضا ضغط لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على مدينه خانيونس التي حتى
هذه اللحظه لم تستطع التوغل ودخول داخل
عمق او قلب مدينه خانيونس التي تعتبرها
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مركز عمليات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ومركز عمليات كتائب
القسام على وجه التحديد اذا نتحدث عن
عمليات عسكريه مركزه في خان يونس وفي
الوقت نفسه عمليات انسحاب لافته من
المنطقه الشماليه لخان يونس وتحديدا بين
خان يونس ودير البلح اذا ما ذهبنا الى
المنطقه الوسطى تركيز كبير على مخيم
البريج للاجئين الفلسطينيين في منطقه في
المنطقه الوسطى يسعى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الى دخول هذا المخيم دخل الى هذا المخيم
ويوم امس اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي عن عن
انفجار شاحنه محمله بالمتفجرات يبدو انها
كانت معده لتفجير الانفاق انفاق المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في هذه المنطقه لكن هذه
الشاحنه انفجرت وادت الى اصابه 30 ومقتل
سته جنود اسرائيليين بينهم ضباط بطبيعه
الحال في منطقه البريج اذا محاولات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للتوغل في البريج رغم
انه يتمكن من التوغل ولكن هذه المحاولات
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يمكن القول بانها ثابته
لم يتمركز الجيش في منطقه البريج رغم انه
يحاول قطع قطاع غزه او خلق فاصل بين
المنطقه الوسطى الشماليه المنطقه الوسطى
البريج وال نسرات الزوايده مع وادي غزه
والمناطق الجنوبيه من مدينه غزه وايضا
يحاول فصل المنطقه الوسطى او شماليه
المنطقه الوسطى عن منطقه دير البلح عفوا
بهذا الشكل يحاول الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فصل
هذه هذا المربع البريج والنصيرات
والزوايده وعندما نتحدث عن ض المربع فهو
مربع صغير بطبيعه الحال اي اننا نتحدث عن
عمق لا يتجاوز 5 مر بهذا الشكل يحاول
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فصله ما زالت
العمليات العسكريه والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
فعاله في المنطقه الشماليه رغم الدمار
الكبير رغم الانسحابات رغم ان جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قال بانه احكم
السيطره على نقاط المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
المنطقه الشماليه لكن مقطع فيديو لكتاب
القسام نشرته يوم امس عن عمليات عسكريه
لها وكمين مركب لها في منطقه الزيتون في
المنطقه الجنوبيه من من مدينه غزه وهي
المنطقه التي تمركزت فيها اليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منذ الايام الاولى للدخول
البري ولكنها حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتمكن من
تدمير كل قدرات المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
مدينه غزه وتحديدا الاحياء الشماليه عبد
السلام هكذا يبدو الوضع في اليوم ال6 لهذه
المعارك لا يمكن القول بان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي استطاع حسم اي من نقاط القوه
له والتمركز بشكل كبير المناطق الشماليه
تحديدا